- Well, Michelle I'd ask
how quarantine has been,
but you have twin toddlers at home.
So basically you need wine and a nanny.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So there's Hazel and
Otis I love them so much.
This has been a joyful marathon.
I just wish I had cleaned
spoons at some point in the day.
I mean, I've never talked
to a dishwasher so often,
but here we are!
- Oh, my gosh. I know,
the cleaning is insane.
So are you like me?
Your only alone time is
maybe in the bathroom?
- Oh, it's my favorite.
I just sit on the toilet
and answer emails.
(Kelly laughs)
- Me too!
- Is that what it is? I
mean, it's really me time.
It's very quiet in there.
I've never enjoyed tile
and porcelain so much.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- It is funny though,
because I always look at
myself while I'm sitting there
with my phone just
trying to be productive.
I don't even take the time to pee.
I just have to be doing
something else like while-
I'm like, "This is an issue
for society, I think."
But Cheryl, so was it like
that with your daughter?
- At my house?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Oh, I sit in the driveway in my car.
- What?
- Yes.
- Yeah, that's my time.
- What? Do you just listen to music? Or-
- Yes, I listen to music.
I talk on the phone.
It's the only place I have any privacy.
So if I want to talk
about anybody in my house,
I have to sit in the car to do it.
- Oh my God, that's so bad.
- I love doing a good therapy session
on the phone in the car,
because then no one in the house can hear
what you're saying about them.
- [Cheryl] Yes, that's right!
- Oh! Man, I should worry about that more.
Yeah, I don't-
(audience laughs)
I just have mine on
speaker phone. I'm like-
- [Cheryl] You let them hear it.
- Like, you're going to hear
it eventually. I'm open.